why is the album called see you next
wednesday
man so i man i go down rabbit holes with
[ __ ] you know what i mean so i
with movies and all that of course john
landis
you know he directed like thriller a
bunch of hit movies in the early 90s
and he would always sneak that into his
movies
see you next wednesday it'd be like a
billboard or like a thriller
when michael jackson gets up to walk out
of the theater
you hear the voice whisper see you next
wednesday in the background
that was like his easter egg and a lot
of his movies right
um so i thought that was cool just just
like that
yeah i was just like oh that's dope as
hell like i'll just you know i want to
pay homage to john landis you know what
i mean
and um i dug deeper obviously the rabbit
hole you know i mean you'd be high as
[ __ ] just
trying to find out more right and
finally
i got to the to the to the gist of the
whole thing is
that was the first script that he wrote
and
it never got made right
and in the in that position that i was
in in that moment it was it was crazy
because when i read that i was like
okay now i know why this is like kind of
calling my name
you know what i mean because the way the
dots connected it it just felt like the
same thing i was going through it's like
i'm making some [ __ ] right now
i don't even know if this is gonna see
the light of day i don't know if i'm
gonna come back to let it see the light
of day
you know what i mean so when you were
working on this project you you were
just working on it for you
you weren't working on it like to to
turn it into your label or to like yo
this is a hit
or you know now you were just working
yeah yeah it was honestly for me it was
like
getting in there and and and testing and
challenging myself
to be like okay what you did yesterday
sucked you know i had to like really
just give myself
talks because you know like i said it
was like relearning all of this [ __ ] you
know you walk away from it for so long
it was always my outlet like my way to
like say things and all that you know so
it was really hard uh to not have that
anymore
to be going through [ __ ] that i want to
talk about and i want to be able to put
in songs but
it's just the way my brain is taking it
it's not letting me
you know what i mean it's not letting me
put nothing on paper i can't
think of nothing witty to say around
these things or nothing poetic to say
around these things it was just too
black and white in my head for me you
know what i mean so
i think it was like a challenge to
myself to get in there every day and be
like
oh [ __ ] that like i'm okay i gotta break
this wall and like
do what i do you know just you know
that's really what i do
best you know so day by day i really
just had to just
build myself back up and you know god
bless the album
ended up being what it was but really if
it didn't go there
and i wasn't as proud as i am of this
project and that really would have been
my see you next wednesday john landis
style